let's say that we have some number a and
two that we are going to add some number
B and that sum is going to be equal to C
now let's say that we're also told that
both a and B are irrational irrational
so based on the information that I've
given you a and B are both irrational is
there some C is that going to be
rational or irrational and encourage you
to pause the video and try to answer
that on your on your own so I'm guessing
that you might have struggled with this
a little bit because the answer is that
we actually don't know it depends on
what irrational numbers a and B actually
are what do I mean by that well I can
pick two irrational numbers where their
sum actually is going to be rational
what do I mean well what if a is equal
to PI and B B is equal to one minus pi
now both of these are irrational numbers
pi is irrational and one minus pi
whatever this value is this is
irrational as well but if we add these
two things together if we add PI plus
one minus PI 1 minus PI well these are
going to add up to be equal to one which
is clearly going to be a rational number
so we were able to find one scenario in
which we added two Irrational's and we
the sum gives us a rational and in
general you could do this trick with any
irrational number instead of Pi you
could have had you could have had square
root of two plus one minus the square
root of two both of these what we have
in this orange color is irrational what
we have in this blue color is irrational
but the sum is going to be rational and
you could do this instead of having one
minus you could have this is one-half
minus you could have done it a bun
of different combinations so that you
could end up with a sum that is rational
but you could also easily add to
irrational numbers and still end up with
an irrational number so for example if a
is PI and B is PI well then you're going
to be their sum is going to be equal to
2 pi which is still irrational or if you
added PI plus the square root of 2 this
is still still going to be irrational in
fact just mathematically I would just
express this as pi plus the square root
of 2 this is some number right over here
but this is still going to be irrational
so the big takeaway is is if you're
taking the sums of two irrational
numbers and people don't tell you
anything else they don't tell you which
specific irrational numbers they are you
don't know whether their sum is going to
be rational or irrational so now let's
think about products so similar exercise
let's say we have a times B is equal to
C a B is equal to C a times B is equal
to C and once again let's say someone
tells you that both a and B are
irrational pause this video and think
about whether C must be rational
irrational or whether we just don't know
and try to figure out some examples like
we just did when we looked at sums all
right so let's think about let's see if
we can construct examples where C ends
up being rational well one thing I as
you can tell I like to use pi PI might
be my favorite irrational number if a
was 1 over PI and B is PI well what's
their product going to be well their
product is going to be 1 over pi times
pi that's just going to be pi over pi
which is equal to 1 so here we got a
situation where the product of two
Irrational's became or is rational but
what if I were
to multiply what if and in general you
could do this with a lot of irrational
numbers 1 over square root of 2 times
the square root of 2 that would be 1 now
what if instead I had pi times pi pi
times pi well that you could just write
as pi squared + pi squared is still
going to be irrational so this is
irrational irrational and it isn't even
always the case that if you multiply the
same the same irrational number if you
square in a rational number that's
always going to be irrational for
example if I have square root of 2 times
I think you see where this is going
times the square root of 2 I'm taking
the product of two irrational numbers in
fact they're the same irrational number
but the square root of 2 times the
square root of 2 well that's just going
to be equal to 2 which is clearly a
rational number so once again when
you're taking the product of two
irrational numbers you don't know
whether the product is going to be
rational or irrational unless someone
tells you the specific numbers so
whether you're taking the product or the
sum of irrational numbers in order to
know whether the resulting number is
irrational rational you need to know
something about what you're taking the
sum or the product of